following the mass shooting in Florida
the left keeps on talking about how to
make students safer and conservatives
have one simple solution Donn's so Kobe
lobby Tim bolts and myself Jordan
Klepper are at CPAC the annual gathering
of conservatives from across the country
to get those deets we have a tremendous
amount of support number one with gun
absolutely mass killings right exactly
well that's two number ones right
exactly
so let wants to talk about gun I find it
very frustrating that they're using
young people and they are putting them
in front of the camera as a political
pawn I think it's disrespectful to these
victims to politicize these things too
quickly even if the victims are
specifically asking us to politicize
them right
liberals keep saying they're like 400
mass shootings a year in America move on
liberals that's right democracy is about
balancing two equally valid points on
one side you have children who want to
live to see the end of the school day on
the other side you have people who want
to own three ar-15 right both equally
valid there you go it's like they're so
polished it's like either I have to
question my deeply held beliefs or
they're lying ever NRA spokesperson
Sheriff David Clarke knows that only one
man had enough cash to bankroll all the
crisis actors George Soros I sheriff
Clark Tim good how are you I just want
to say I appreciate everything that
you've said about Soros being behind the
never again movement but he's a bad guy
he's also like he needs it just makes me
furious when you get 18 year old honor
students to carry guns as well
right sheriff Clark is right it's
amazing what we won't do to prevent mass
shootings like anything at all all these
movies make heroes out of people with
mental deficiencies look at Hollywood
there is the Green Mile there is Forrest
Gump you're drawing a line between
Forrest Gump and and school shootings
that's a line people are afraid to draw
yeah too often people are like oh
shooting with an ar-15 having an ar-15
and they connect these dots nobody has
the guts to connect like shooting with
an ar-15 Forrest Gump that's it it's
just a lack of imagination
I sent him in to see what the big dogs
are saying about guns by the way if you
only had a choice of one what would you
rather have the Second Amendment or the
tax cuts go ahead I'm gonna leave it at
the Second Amendment I don't want to get
into that right I feel like the founding
fathers they saw that they're like we
know what's eventually gonna happen we
need 19 year olds to be able to have
ar-15 so the second member is very clear
and it talks about the militia the
Constitution is famously unamended
correct I'm constantly telling that to
my slaves
and never forget these work to stop a
bad guy with a gun in case a good guy
[Applause]
the best part of CPAC no one is talking
about gun control instead we keep
hearing one common solution charming
teaches you against our teachers weaken
our teachers arm all these teachers I
want to put more firearm in school I
want to see more teachers armed and
multi should be arming the cashier at
gadzooks right or the Hot Topic person
Pearson ears they should have an AR the
janitor crossing guards got a gun they'd
respect it don't walk sign that am i
right when you think of the NRA strategy
in response to the never again movement
the student from Parkland in particular
pretty so talking about the like harming
teachers for example I think it's a
pretty good idea oh wait no I'm not
talking about they're not strategy about
arming teachers I mean right talking
about their strategy of like kind of
changing the subject away from gun
control okay yeah I guess I think it's
important there he is
the second most famous lash of the NRA
Dana's husband Chris lash and I said
Kobe to pick his brain the school that
my children go to have protocols they
have locked doors you have to be buzzed
in and there are people there that are
willing to respond and our armed because
we care about our children again so you
put them in prison they're not in prison
that's ridiculous right it's just give
the buzz all right how many more guns
will make our school safe you tell me
ten more guns where I don't know they
just scattered about how many working 50
go I'm asking you with 50 guns make our
school say 75 one honey
thank you so much I'm a big fan why not
please move back
no no I don't have a gun it's okay I
don't have a gun silly Coby these people
would have felt safer if you did have a
gun that's why the NRA strategy is to
always hijack the debate to talk about
anything except fewer guns like arming
teachers good guys with guns Mental
Health Hollywood George Soros a hit hate
what were we even talking about if you
don't know just follow the crowd now I
feel sick